oh let me tell you something okay can I
go off on a tangent for a second I don't
like like fantasy or sci-fi stuff that's
why I never saw Star Wars like I used to
have a rule like if it didn't happen or
it couldn't happen then I just wasn't
interested like Leo made me watch the
Mandalorian when we were making don't
look up and it was like baby Yoda was so
cute but I just didn't give a [ __ ]
because I didn't know anything that was
like it was about or anything I had
never seen Game of Thrones never seen an
episode and I started in the past couple
months Game of Thrones
is so sick I know this is like hilarious
because I'm like in 2012 but I forget
this happened in real time and was like
a cultural event so I watched the Red
Wedding and I'm like calling friends
like oh my God like Rob Stark got killed
blah blah blah and they're like they're
like yeah dude it was like it was like
the end of Sopranos level cultural event
the Red Wedding and I'm just like oh can
you believe this oh my God